ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute befassen wir uns mit Michel fou
Diskurstheorie ich sag ein bisschen was
zu Michelle fou er ist einer der
bedeutendsten intellektuellen des 20
Jahrhunderts häufig wird er auch mit der
Bewegung der Strömung der Postmoderne
Poststrukturalismus in Verbindung
gebracht auch Strukturalismus also die
Reflexion auf Strukturen auf Zeichen
Systeme auf Ordnungen die sich erst auf
den zweiten Blick zeigen und auf
Ordnungen die man auch archäologisch
also in dem man in die Tiefe kräbt zu
Tage fördern und dann auch in weiteren
Schritt kritisieren kann und das ist vor
allem der Punkt bei Michelle fouco es
geht um Diskurse was es ist werde ich
noch genauer sagen und um ihre
Identifikation und um ihre Kritik
es lohnt sich immer die jeweiligen
Begriffe wie jetzt dieser Begriff des
Diskurses im größeren Kontext der
Grundbegriffe der politischen
Philosophie zu diskutieren und der
Begriff des Diskurses und auch der
Diskurs Kritik steht im Kontext der
Begriffe von macht Herrschaft
Ideologie das sind die drei anderen
Begriffe der politischen Philosophie die
mit dem Begriff des Diskurses und der
Kritik sehr eng
zusammenhängen ein weiterer wichtiger
Begriff der jetzt kein wirklich
politischer Begriff ist aber der auch
eine große Rolle spielt ist bei F der
Begriff der
Sprache Sprache ist nach F nicht nur ein
Medium zum bezeichnen von Dingen sondern
es ist ein Machtinstrument das ist so
sein Ansatz und natürlich ist er da
nicht der einzige der für die politische
Philosophie die sprach in Blick genommen
hat Jürgen habermaß z.B dann mache ich
oben rechts ein linkrein hat sich in
seiner Theorie des kommunikativen
Handeln sehr intensiv mit der Bedeutung
sprachlicher Kommunikation für die
Politik befasst der Unterschied ist
allerdings der dass bei habbermaße sich
immer um eine ideale Sprecher Situation
handelt das heißt man nimmt an dass der
Diskurs von dem auch spricht dass der
idealen Bedingungen geheucht und dass er
dem besseren Argument folgt dem Zwang
des besseren arguments da könnte man
jetzt sagen dass ist ein sehr
idealistischer diskursbegriff vielleicht
auch ein bisschen unkritischer
diskursbegriff das kann man sich fragen
jedenfalls ist das die aufweisung von
habermaß dass der Diskurs der rationale
Diskurs die politische Macht bestimmen
soll derjenige diejenige bekommt die
macht die das bessere Argument hat durch
den Diskurs durch unsere sprachliche
Kommunikation anders hingegen sieht es
jetzt er zieht den Diskurs auch als ein
Machtinstrument aber eher als ein
problematisches Machtinstrument er lenkt
nämlich den Blick auf die anonymen
kollektive und Strukturen die nennt er
auch dispositive die unseren sprach und
machtdiskurs bestimmen er V Co geht also
davon aus dass wir nicht im unseren
Diskurs selbst bestimmen können wie es
habberma annimmt durch den Zwang des
besseren arguments SN dass wir immer
schon wenn wir in einem Diskurs uns
aufhalten Zwängen unterliegen die wir
gar nicht auf den ersten Blick einsehen
und das ist deswegen eine Form von
Fremdbestimmung eine diskursive
Fremdbestimmung die die Macht versucht
zu
lenken jetzt geht es F um die Ordnung
des Diskurses das ist eine Wendung von
ihm es geht also um die
Machtverhältnisse die festlegen die
dispositive wie man z.B über krank und
gesund spricht also wie man
dascheidungen einführt häufig sind es im
Sinne des Strukturalismus binäre
Oppositionen Abgrenzungen die die
Orientierung erleichtern das haben auch
Ideologien an sich die immer gut versus
böse ausspielen und die natürlich auch
macht dadurch zu schreiben V Macht
sichern wollen macht
legitimieren er versucht jetzt
politische Machtverhältnisse so zu
relativieren dass er sie historisiert
dass er also auf die Genese auf die
Entstehung dieser
Machtverhältnisse hinweist und das ist
natürlich immer eine Relativierung wenn
man sagt das war nicht schon immer so
sondern das hat sich erst formiert und
zwar durch bestimmte Funktionen und
Strategien er möchte also das Individuum
das autonome Individuum von diskursiven
Zwängen befreien die es ohne dass es es
weiß fremdbestimmen Heteronomie
politische Heteronomie bezüglich der
Macht ich hatte es schon gesagt der
Diskurs ist nach fo kein rein
sprachliches Medium der Beschreibung der
Bezeichnung kein linguistisches Phänomen
sonder eher etwas was die Pragmatik
anbelangt also die Frage was wir mit
Wörtern mit Sprache tun mehr noch ist es
ein Machtinstrument das nicht nur
vorgefundene Realitäten beschreibt
sondern allererst erzeugt durch
Unterscheidungen durch Fixierungen durch
verschiedene Mechanismen die bestehen
z.B darin dass kontrolliert wird ob man
wie über was sprechen darf dass man auch
erlaubt wer redet Verknappung der
Ressourcen es gibt also ganz
verschiedene Mechanismen wie die
dispositive den Diskurs lenken und
kontrollieren Verbote ist ein wichtiger
Mechanismus aber eben auch wie ich schon
gesagt hatte normative Setzungen
Unterscheidungen die häufig binär sind
wie z.B Wahnsinn und Vernunft oder auch
Irrationalität und Rationalität dadurch
legitimiert der Diskurs seine eigene
Rationalität die natürlich nicht wie bei
habermaß idealistisch gedacht wird dass
sie dem Zwang des besseren arguments
folgt s den Wille Z macht um in
Nietzsche zu reden der für V auch eine
große Rolle gespielt hat ja das war eine
ganz kurze Einführung in F Diskurs
Theorie vor dem Hintergrund der
Grundbegriff
der politischen Philosophie ich bedanke
mich für die Aufmerksamkeit ich mache
unten links einen Link zur Playlist rein
da kann man sich noch mal in aller Ruhe
alle Sendungen dieses Seminars ansehen
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit